the gp system is the front door of the
nhs
walk in and you can receive face-to-face
contact with your family doctor
but in the age of coronavirus surgeries
like grey park terrace and west london
have had to transform what they do as
you go into a patient's record
it also links to the patient's telephone
system and doctors like glennis williams
think that even when the pandemic
recedes
digital gp appointments are here to stay
we made a decision that we were going to
increase our
remote consultations which was probably
around
10 percent of our service mainly
telephone consultations
to about 1995 for doctors so your
remote appointments have gone from 10 to
90 to 90 90 that's a huge change
it is a huge change but we've also
upgraded the way we do remote
consultations using video consultations
um and it means that the patients have
to have a smartphone
but it also means we can have a visual
inspection
and be able to deliver the same service
and how do you think it's been working
i think it's an advantage for the
patients and ourselves it's safe
because they're at home in their
convenient comfortable environment
there's no risk of infection we don't
have to wear ppe
um and they we can access them wherever
they are
so i've had patients calling me from
even portugal and
devon and scotland it might feel like
i'm stating the obvious but growth
terrorist surgery is quiet it's really
quiet the vast majority of their work is
now done digitally which has
obviously got certain benefits that can
continue postcovid
but i can't help wondering if the lack
of physical contact with patients
is storing up health problems for the
future the royal college of general
practitioners welcomes the convenience
of online appointments
but they are concerned about a fall in
cancer referrals and childhood
vaccinations
the issues that we've seen unrelated to
coronavirus but i guess some of the
consequences of lockdown could be
storing up health issues for the future
i mean have we seen a fall in the number
of people going to gp surgeries
yeah that's a major concern for us in
general practice so
we know from data that uh the royal
ecology general practitioners has
collected that
the number of consultations at the
height of the crisis was down by
around about 24-25 percent that's
millions of people
yeah a lot of people an awful lot of
people we see a million people a day so
an awful lot of people so we know that
was a problem we know that patients
in many cases were anxious about
overloading the nhs so they were holding
on to their problems
we know that a lot of patients were
anxious about picking up an infection if
they had to
go into their general practice or go
into hospital so for a range of reasons
patients were staying away
and the consequences we've got a backlog
which now as the crisis moves on
we're just starting to pick up in
general practice and some
some of the people that we haven't seen
you know people who perhaps didn't need
to see a general practitioner in the
first place but
quite a few of them will be people
who've got significant health problems
who needed
input from from health professionals and
didn't get it at the time of the crisis
there's been some
uh people who've been saying that
actually the number of people who die
from
uh things that are related to the
lockdown could even be higher than those
who
die from cope at 19. do you think that's
realistic well
that is a risk we know from previous
pandemics that in some cases
both in the uk um and and in and
internationally that
uh often the mortality rate from
conditions that aren't directly related
to the infection is greater than the
infection itself so that is a real risk
andrew lansley the health secretary from
2010 to 2012 believes a transformed
family doctor system
will always be at the heart of the
health service the nature of their role
might and should
change that it shouldn't simply be um
seeing 40 patients a day and um
making the appropriate referral or
prescribing the right
approach they should actually be
managing the health of their population
lord lansley oversaw a reorganization of
the nhs when he was health secretary
including the creation of public health
england its response to coronavirus has
been criticized
and on friday the health secretary matt
hancock ordered an
urgent review into the way it collects
the daily death numbers for kovic 19 in
england
without taking into account those who
have recovered from the virus
speculation is mounting that public
health england could be axed
amid criticism that ministers don't have
enough control over it
nobody is going to scrap phe the point
is before
where this particular responsibility is
concerned
before 2013 we had the health protection
agency
all of the relevant powers
and resources and people were
transferred uh as an on block
from the health protection agency into
public health england so anybody who
says
the response of public health england
was somehow changed by the 2012-13
reforms i'm afraid it's simply
wrong public health england is an agency
of the department of health
the legislation that the law provides
for
direct control by the government by the
secretary of state
of the activities of public health
england so not only does
the secretary of state have all the
required powers it also has
all the required control and actually in
a public health emergency
that also applies to the nhs in an
emergency
the law provides that the secretary of
state has power of direction
to the nhs not only at the center but to
individual nhs trusts
so i'm afraid anybody in government who
tries to say
we didn't have enough power is frankly
either deluding themselves
or trying to mislead other people
coronavirus has tested the nhs like
nothing before
whether intensive care awards public
health england or gp
surgeries the uncertainty is that the
health service has transformed
and there will be no going back